janet yellen was wrong dead wrong about
inflation and now she is admitting it we
have a clip here from janet yellen
talking exactly about that let's play it
real quick
i think i was wrong then about
the path that inflation
would take as i mentioned there have
been unanticipated
and large shocks to the economy that
have boosted
energy and food prices and
supply bottlenecks that have affected
our economy badly that i didn't at the
time didn't fully understand
what do you mean you didn't fully
understand what what she uh also said at
the time that it was a small risk given
what was happening in the global economy
as they were talking about a 1.9
trillion dollar infrastructure and
coveted relief package and now we've
we've printed at this point i think six
plus billion trillion dollars and many
more money after that so let's take a
look at the inflation rate which is the
consequence of some of this stuff
charlie bellio put together an excellent
chart or graph here that shows the
inflation rates for all different goods
and services if you look at fuel
80 year-over-year change from the april
2022 cpi report gas 43 used cars 22 gas
utilities 22
meat fish poultry eggs you hungry 14
new egg new cars 13 electricity 11 food
at home 10 transportation 8.5 overall
cpi eight point three percent but even
food away uh from home apparel and
shelter is up five percent to seven
percent real estate whole different game
we've seen apartments uh not only going
for 25 rating increases 50 rate
increases and even higher than that home
prices the average home price in the
united states right now is over five
hundred thousand dollars the average the
median if you wanna put in that context
still over four hundred thousand dollars
and if you go look at those charts
they're going up a little bit up a
little bit and then boom and a lot of
that is due to what we've done from an
injection standpoint of the money that
we put in the global economy so we have
another quote here uh from the treasury
the official quote this is what they
said uh in response and they said the
secretary was pointing out that there
have been shocks to the economy that
have been exasperated inflationary
pressures which couldn't have been
foreseen 18 months ago including
russia's decision to invade ukraine
multiple successive variants of covet
and lockdowns in china
what the hell are they talking about
russia invaded ukraine a few months ago
and they were blaming it on they were
blaming inflation on russia literally
two days after the invasion happened
putin's price hike yeah putin's price
like y'all remember people don't forget
that's literally what they were doing
they were blaming russia two days after
it happened
everyone could have seen this coming
which is my point right
she's held very very very important
positions right the federal reserve
chair uh secretary of the treasury et
cetera she's been in government for a
long time she's been uh in economics for
a long time she studied a lot of these
things
bitcoiners literally people on the
internet random people on the internet
with twitter accounts we're screaming
saying that this was going to happen
everyone knew it was going to happen
which leads me to believe that you have
to look at the incentives for a bunch of
these things right you tell people they
can't go home covet happens i get it
right you want to slow it down you want
to make sure everyone can do what they
do but you tell businesses they can't
work you tell people they cannot work
you send everyone home you inject a
bunch of money into the economy and as
you're talking about two trillion
dollars three trillion dollars five
trillion dollars six trillion dollar
stimulus packages and money printing
you're saying that we don't think this
is gonna be inflationary
what like come on
you knew that was going to happen to
what extent sure maybe you could argue
the supply chain obviously caused part
of it but at the end of the day everyone
saw how much money was being printed at
one point i believe it was like 50 plus
percent of the money in circulation was
due to money printing was newly created
money
anytime that happens when you debase a
currency like that you're going to get
inflationary pressure and we've seen
that over the last year we've seen that
over the last two years and now she's
admitting she's literally saying we knew
this was going to happen or we or we
didn't expect it but now we see that it
did happen to the point it was never
non-existent it was never transitory it
was certainly never good for you and
it's been here for a long period of time
which goes back to our original point of
everyone needs to protect themselves
when this money was being printed the
absolute best thing you could have been
doing is be an investor his own assets
assets that appreciated during this the
stock market went to the moon bitcoin
went to the moon real estate prices went
to the moon and the people that got hurt
the most are the 45 percent of americans
that do not own investable assets they
live paycheck to paycheck and spend a
large the majority of their paycheck on
things like gasoline on things like
shelter on food transportation all the
inflationary things that went up
tremendously when the rich people the
wealthy people the top one percent the
top 10 or the people that own assets
spend a very very very very small
portion of their income on those things
and benefited tremendously i think that
they knew that this was going to happen
i don't see how you can print all that
money and not expect some inflationary
pressures sure maybe supply chains
things made it worse maybe the war has
now made it worse maybe there's other
things going on i get that nuance but to
say that you didn't expect it then to
say it was transitory then to say it was
good for you and not to come out and
admit that you were wrong and inflation
has been here it's been elevated and you
don't know why seems very insincere and
i think it speaks to a lot of the people
in power today elected officials and why
to be quite frank we need something like
bitcoin right that the monetary policy
is very clear it doesn't depend on a
meeting it doesn't depend on how
someone's feeling that day it doesn't
depend on other outside things it
literally is written in code everyone
knows exactly what is going to happen
and you can make your decision based off
that what do you think john i give her a
little credit
janet young for one admitting that she
was wrong years ago when she initially
talked about inflation she said in march
2021 it was there was a small risk of
inflation it was manageable there are a
ton of things like you mentioned that
have come up and she also mentioned
obviously that have come up over the
last few years to increase or accelerate
the inflation that we're seeing here in
america but yeah almost all of it um or
i'd call it 80 if i had to pick a number
out of a hat
that's due to what they did in the
economy and they should have foreseen
that we've been talking about it for
pretty much a year year and a half two
years at this point now internally um
that inflation was going to be super
high because they were printing a ton of
money they were literally handing out
checks even to billionaires they're
giving george soros got a
government stimulus check right so this
was government created instead of
calling it putin's price hike you might
as well just call it the united states
government price hike because that's
what they did to the american people the
people who don't have investable assets
are getting hurt and it's also creeping
into the higher um
the higher income earners right so i
read a stat today that was uh was it 36
of americans that make over 250k now
live paycheck to paycheck
yes it's it's incredible and what
they've done
is and people don't like to talk about
this and they certainly don't like to
talk about it because people claim that
uh people are scaring people about
inflation rich people love inflation
they would literally sit there in
silence and talk about it and talk about
it amongst themselves but never publicly
because they own assets that is very
obvious they own a ton of assets that
are investable and they go up in value
when more money is pumped into the
economy when volatility increases they
own things that will increase in value
homes equity in companies things like
that right bitcoin other things so at
the end of the day what they've done
though is they've divided and they've
they've grown the wealth and quality gap
especially in the united states to
levels that we have never seen or at
least haven't seen in a long long long
time and the reason why that's happening
is exactly what we mentioned earlier
which is they pumped a bunch of money
into the system people that own assets
appreciated they saw that appreciation
they benefited tremendously to the
upside and everyone else the 45 of
americans that don't own any investable
assets got punished they literally we
pulled up the chart the other day they
got a five percent raise too bad you
lost money last year yeah right you're
now making less money year over year
because everything that you're buying
the basket of goods that you're buying
on an annual basis or a daily basis has
gone up tremendously in value they say
8.3 on an average i think it's higher
than that i think a lot of other people
think it's higher than that we've seen
evidence that would indicate that it's
higher than that so ultimately like
everyone's in a different scenario
you're buying different things all these
everyone has different jobs you're
getting raises maybe you're not getting
raised whatever but at the end of the
day a lot of americans are worse off
than they were previously and i think
it's probably insincere to some degree
to say we didn't expect that to happen
right you printed money you knew what
was gonna happen literally there was how
many people were on the internet saying
we're gonna be locked down for an
extended period of time there's gonna be
another string like people knew this
stuff and they're called conspiracy
theorists they're called idiots they're
called insane a lot of times and in some
instances there are people on that side
of the aisle that are wrong about some
of these things but in a lot of other
instances it almost becomes the
consensus to some degree where people
realize that this is what is happening
and then people uh in the fed and other
places are late to react or are just
very insincere in their actions right
because when you're printing that much
money thank god someone said in the chat
that uh the last plan didn't pass build
build back america or whatever and build
better build back better yeah
because that would have been devastating
to add that much more money into the
economy and print that much more money
from an inflationary standpoint so
everyone that was saying oh you don't
want to give money to america the people
that shut it down right
republicans and other people they said
you don't want to give stimulus no the
people that are getting money a lot of
times in some instances some people do
realize but in some other instances they
do not even realize what is happening to
them right they think that they're just
getting money from the government free
money who doesn't want free money you're
gonna give me money hell yeah give me
money but at the end of the day what
it's doing is if they give you five
dollars and you go to buy a coffee
that's six dollars and now that coffee
is eight dollars like are you better or
worse off right because that five
dollars gonna be gone pretty quick
especially when you think about it in
context of how long were we locked down
for right
couple years almost in some places uh
and how much money do people really get
right businesses got help more obviously
but individuals they got a few checks
and that's it and now you live in a
world where everything is tremendously
more expensive and you're worse off than
you were before because you also didn't
appreciate that upside completely agree
uh what is it interest rates are up
personal savings are down personal debt
consumer debt is up this is just a this
is a terrible storm for the american
person right now